hello everyone welcome back to the kappa
blanka saga we are back at the 1914
tournament of some pitcher Berg and
Capablanca faces a very strong opponent
it's dr. Isaac Burt arash with the white
pieces this is the second game the two
of them have ever played the first one
we've already seen it it's the one from
the 1911 tournament in San Sebastian
where tariffs or again had the white
pieces and the Dead game ended in a draw
some thirty five moves if I remember
correctly and in that game we had the
Italian game now I just want to mention
before we check out this game it's a
very nice game but previous game we've
seen that brilliance again Stassi
Bernstein and capablanca created already
to brilliance is against Austin
Bernstein and most of the times you will
her hear about AUSA Bernstein if you're
not really studying chess history most
likely we'll hear his name when he loses
the game to capablanca ah but you should
not judge his skill by you know bringing
out the best in josé raúl capablanca
to take him down he was a an excellent
player one of the best of that of that
era and you know there's definitely a
great player so don't judge the man by
by losing to brilliance is to to one of
the greatest players who ever played
chess Alberto came that being said here
a couple Monica's opponent is dr. Silber
Terra she is probably twice his age but
he has already defeated many many of the
strongest players that ever even lived
and welcome Blanca will not take him
lightly especially after the game in a
Sun sebastiaan tournament and without
further ado let's check out this very
nice game start opens with E for as he
did in San Sebastian three years ago
with E 5 ignites to f3 Knight to c6 and
here in San Sebastian if you wanna bash
up to c4 here he goes to Bishop to b5 so
we have Derulo PES and Tasha she is also
having a pretty excellent tournament
except for the round 1 loss he was
todavía no scatter than that he's doing
quite alright we have a 6 kappa blanka
goes for more fees defense rush up to a
4 nice to f6 Knight to c3 and Bishop to
e7
we have D 3 d6 all pretty standard and
here as
chose this the sex idea Terrax decides
to lose the tempo some what an unusual
idea they immediately go for d4 here so
first d3 and only then d for and the cup
of one cup plays Bishop to d7 you don't
want to allow b5 and well kappa blanka
could capture here Bishop to d7 is
better Bishop captures on c6 tariff
decides to give up the bishop pair with
Bishop captures now comes Queen to d3
defending the e4 pawn he captures on d4
Knight captures something for attacking
the bishop capablanca goes back to the 7
and now Castle
we have castles by Capablanca as well
and now rook to e1 so not really all
that advantageous for white but tarush
did manage to keep plenty of the pieces
on the board and not allow capablanca to
go straight in some sort of an endgame
and it's most likely a line that
Capablanca is not familiar with we have
rook to e8 by capablanca and now comes
h3 h 6 ball players waste pretty much
waste a move to make some breathing
space for the King but also ok white is
taking away the g4 square from black's
knight and the shippin black is taking
away the g5 square from white submission
and now comes queen to g3 tarush is now
threatening Bishop captures on a 6 as
the pawn on g7 is pinned capablanca
moves the King on pins and now
developing with the bishop to d2
we have Bishop to f8 and now Capablanca
rook is also participating in the game
also the bishop gives some more
protection to the king side and Queen
back to d3 so not really a clear plan as
to what tariff she's doing but so far
it's it's hard to say that he would have
any advantage even though he has the
white pieces we are c6 by Capablanca
preparing expansion on the Queen set but
also Blackwood they definitely want to
push the 5 to get rid of pretty much his
only weakness in the position rook 831
Terra sure now
completes the development and now Queen
to e7 we have a knight back Knight back
to f3 now with ideas of maybe pushing a
5 but now Bishop to e6 and here a e5 is
a possibility but after the characters
Knight captures black would be in an
Oprah
after Queen to c7 just getting the Queen
under leaf I'll add the rope is coming
to d8 and all is well for black so here
we have Bishop to f4 by Tarrasch going
after the d6 pawn but now comes Luke 8
to d8
capablanca also pretty much finishes
development and Quinta III getting the
Queen out of the D file but also perhaps
considering some ideas of infiltrating
along the Queen side files and now you
can see that blacksmith shop is quite
useful even though it's kind of weird
NFAT as it prevents against ideas like
Bishop captures on h6 captures captures
with the Queen 9 g5 some sort of an
attack against the black King and a cup
of vodka please d5 and it's it's usually
said that if black can push d5 and you
know equalize without without giving any
concessions then white missed something
in the opening and he's no longer better
and such is the case here white
definitely is not better here he
captures on d5 with Knight captures
Knight captures and now comes bushel
captures Capablanca now manages to trade
Queen's Queen captures with Bishop
captures not immediately going for the
rook trade and here we have a very
interesting moment here okay da to pawn
is under attack but you don't really
want to capture immediately because you
know you'd go
Spassky Fischer you know but above white
could go b3 prepare c4 just continue
playing the game but here tarush had a
different idea here teres played rook
captures on e7 and what's his plan here
Capablanca of course recaptures with
rook captures and now c4 and it seems
okay now okay the bishop will move you
will give back the pawn rook will
capture rook with check this is
definitely excellent for for white but
he missed an idea by Capablanca so here
you should imagine that you know you're
playing a game against your friend or an
opponent in a very strong tournament and
your opponent just plays rook captures
on e7
it's some of you weren't expecting or
maybe you were and you know you're ready
for it you recapture and he plays c4 so
what do you do here with black i feel
free to pause the video here and try to
you know refute black's plan i'll give
you a couple seconds as usual for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are
excellent refueler of plants that don't
work and for those who who just wanna
enjoy show
rook to e4 the bishop on f4 is unguarded
and also you wouldn't mind grabbing this
pawn that's kind of harassing your
Bishop on d5 so now you don't have time
to capture here because rook captures
and then white is just updated black is
just up the exchange so after tariff win
Bishop to e3
we now have rook captures on c4 grabbing
this as well but okay it's not just that
tarah from blundered here tariff does
have an idea he goes Knights the e5 and
it's a very nice move the rook is under
attack and if the rook moves for example
if capablanca were to play room before
ago after they spawn then Knight
captures on f7 will be deadly
it's a check the rook is nicely forked
and you will it remove the king and then
lose the rook or you will capture the
night and then you lose the roof with
check after King moves Bishop to d4
defends the pawn and you know you don't
want to do something like captures then
rook comes here attacks g7 and the white
would definitely be better here not much
but better so after 95 capablanca plays
rook to b8 he gives up he gives back the
exchange but once the protected the b7
pawn so after this exchange happens
which did happen rook to d7 does not
come with an attack against the b7 pawn
so it's not a free rook lift we have a
three now not allowing the shop captured
because now it definitely is a threat
and now rush up to d5 closing off the D
file from tariffs rook we look to e1
transferring the rook over to the other
open file on the board which is the
e-file and now rook to d8 by kappa
blanka
Bishop to b6 and now comes Luke to d7
and here Terra is down upon so basically
he blundered upon with that whole idea
where he tried to play fancy and he now
wishes to take this into an opposite
color bishops endgame which he is very
confident in himself that he can hold to
a draw so he goes group to it check we
have King to h7 and now King to h2 first
preparing rook to d8 we have Bishop to
c4 and now comes Luke to d8 here kibou
Lanka decided to move the bishop so he
doesn't have to trade rooks here now
can move the rook if the bishop pair
remained on the default perhaps it could
have been a target later
now comes Luke to e7 and here we have
looked the d4 attacking the cup of blanc
as a bishop bishop goes back to d5 and
now a for a couple of month of course as
we mentioned does not want to trade
rooks
the opposite called Bishop endgame with
is most likely to result in a draw so
Luke - e - now attacking the B to pawn
but also the F do pawn but this was
Terrace idea before as the F DuPont is
protected with a tactic if you capture
here then yes you're threatening some
very nasty stuff here but rook captures
on d5 and black and white is just better
I don't want to capture first so first
you would have to capture with check
King captures and only after capturing
here you would get this endgame where
kappa blanka would be up three pawns but
down a piece so would it be playable
it's hard to say most likely black would
end up playing for a draw let's say king
of three king g6 can get for you could
go f6 create a wall here against the
white king but then just King III you
want to go here King a5 King before King
e6 and it's hard to say but you know a
piece a piece is a piece most likely at
some point black will run out of move so
white will be able to control all of the
points here and on this side of the
board with the bishop and spawn and it
will be black who will be struggling for
a draw if it's at all possible and if it
you know if it was possible to go for
this with black couple Blanca would have
done so
so after this b4 move you cannot capture
an f2 immediately but here capablanca
finds an excellent plan here he plays a5
and what's the idea with a 5 well you
either play Bishop captures
then row captures an f2 is just winning
there are no more tricks Woodrow
captures on d5 and there's really no way
- well you could go wrong g4 to defender
but then g5
pretty much traps your rook here for the
rest of the game guarding this F 5 is
coming f4 f3 and it will just become
very unpleasant for white and eventually
white will lose so after this a5 move
you could just waste a move and wait for
pawn captures which is not something
you want to do and so a captures the be
captures on a fight was played by Irish
and now what capablanca did here is he
successfully created a past steep on and
Capablanca x' beep on will be very
successful in defending against both
doubled a points here so we have looked
the see to first preparing c5 look the
before and now c5 we have looked to f4
and now Bishop back to e6
so now capablanca will simply move his
rook and start pushing his passport how
will tower defend against this well
we'll just have to wait and see we have
rook to f3 the c3 is a dark square so
tariff will now create a blockade he
will put his rook here the control c3
and also his dark square bishop will
help out in in protecting the c3 square
and what would black having only a light
square bishop this pawn will not be able
to cross a dark square something you
always wanna you know keep an eye out
for we have C 4 by kappa blanka
Bishop to d4 now controlling this the
dark square twice but now comes Luke 2
a2
capablanca creates a second weakness
which which are the doubled a pawns and
as you all know there is nothing a look
likes more than a doubled pawn perhaps
maybe a back ranked mate but other than
that you know a doubled pawn is a very
very nice King the g1 tarish now tries
to bring his King into the game we have
rook captures on e4 and now Bishop the
c3 blockading the the c4 pawn but also
guarding the a5 pawn we've looked back
to a 2 now comes rook to g3 pressuring
the g7 pawn by the rook and by the
Bishop g5 now and now comes Luke - III
now immediately going for a5 is not
possible due to rook captures on e6 rook
the c2 now putting pressure on this
bishop so here if King to f1 then ideas
like f5 maybe would be possible if rook
captures then you would eliminate this
this bishop but it's still most likely
to result in a draw but first Aras goes
to Bishop to d4 now we have roof to c1
check forcing the King back King to h2
now King to g6 starting to bring the
King into the game King the g3 by tarush
and now comes Luke the d1 attacking the
bishop and Bishop to c3 and here rook to
d3 is an interesting idea but even after
rook captures pawn captures you are
never crossing a dark square with your
with your passport and also the bishop
is very nicely controlled in da pond
which is on a dark square most likely we
would have a nice drawn game here
so after Bishop to C 3 we have Bishop to
d5 first now with some ideas of going
rogue g1 and rook captures here so we
have f3 blocking the bishop and now
comes Luke the c1 again now putting
pressure on Tatars Bishop on c3 c1 and
c3
Bishop to d4 and now rook the c2 and
here Capablanca is testing the tarush if
tariffs were to play something like
Bishop to c3 just repeat moves and hope
for a draw it doesn't work because now
white is lost
it's a nice position you know just when
you think you have an opposite color
bishop in game the rooks are still on
the board so the game is still very much
playable if tariffs were to play this
again pause the video and try to figure
out how to win this with the black
pieces I'll give you a couple of seconds
as I usually do for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations you
are an excellent winner of winning end
games and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show f5 and now you can see
that there is no way for this rook to
remain on e3 because f4 is a terrible
threat which checks the king and would
win the rook but also the rook has to
stay there to keep an eye on the bishop
so to prevent both threats you would
have to go king h2 now f4 kicks the rook
away but now rookie 5 will trade bishops
but after now rook captures rook
captures you will get King to f6 and now
the King is too far away to successfully
play the same game black will eventually
win this for example rook c5
you want to put the rogue behind the
past pawn either your own pond or your
opponent's pawn give me 6 now comes King
he won king d6 for the rook back rook c8
king b5 now king f2 coming into the game
but now rook to a3 makes the room for
the King to start pushing the passport
all the way and also you will win
spawn and then the other pond comes
marching forward as well so pretty much
there are a lot of winning ideas here
for black so Tara does not try to repeat
moves and make this mistake you know
Tara she's a very successful chess
player
so rook to a3 tariff prepares a six will
F 5 by capablanca now comes a six and
here first
f4 with check you don't want to play
something like king before and run into
this rook captures an G do checkmate you
always have to watch out for ideas like
this King to h2 and now comes B captures
on a6 rook captures on a6 and now it's
well not lucky but very nicely
calculated my target that's this
grabbing of the pawn comes with a check
because kappa blanka would be ready to
capture a bunch of characters on f3 due
to the Jeep on being being pinned we
have King back to f7 and now comes King
to g1 Tarrasch now again wants to
improve the position of his King and
also not allow Bishop captures on f3 and
here we have h5 this is a move which
pretty much blunders the game for kappa
blanka it's it was a major rather
hastily because here this allows rook to
f6 check with chitara immediately played
here after this instead of this h5 move
the only way to continue playing this
for an advantageous capablanca is still
up a pass up a passed pawn is rook to d2
you attack the bishop and after Bishop
the c3 rook to d3 but still after the
rook comes to a3 it's hard to imagine
that you would ever be able to force
this bishop and rook away from from the
dark squares even though you're up a
passed pawn which is you know sad but if
there was a way to continue playing this
game it would be this
unfortunately for a couple blanca he
played h5 or maybe he just calculated
that the idea i've just shown is no
better i he played h5 and he'll out this
rook to f6 check King to e7 was played
and now after up to a5 zebra Terrace and
josé raúl capablanca agreed to a draw so
the second game they ever played the
first one like we said the Italian game
second one the real Lopez both games
played by white from Terra's perspective
were drawn because now well your Bishop
is under attack ug5 pawn is under attack
Oh kinky sex you lose the G pawn and
then we have this very nice
and him that both players agreed it was
a draw as Capablanca did not cover this
game in any of his books I still don't
have towers book so I don't know if he
covered it in his book couldn't find
information so maybe the game was even
adjourned here and then they just
decided that you know the end game is
drawn but we could play it out let's say
Roxy one check King F - Roxy - check
King G 1c3 now you would get rook to e5
check King d6 and now rook captures on
h5 Bishop to c4 Bishop - sorry Bishop to
e5 check we have King to c6 and now King
daddy one attacking the rook rook the -
check and now you would go let's say
King you want and now you either go for
the Jeep on or you deliver this check if
you go for the check then King d1 you
could go see - check King c1 and now of
course you would like to immediately
finish this you want to prepare rook to
e1 check but your deponent c2 is
unguarded Bishop d3 but now Bishop
captures on f4 will guard the queening
square and white will be just up a few
points but all you know a drone endgame
and on the other hand if you don't go
for this
if after King you want you go for rook
captures on g2 then you just get Bishop
captures on c3 you no longer have your
priced a passed C pawn rookie to check
King b1 rook to e3 and going after the
pawn here and now we just trade
everything there should be five rook
captures rook to h4 goes after the f4
pawn bishop to e6 attacks the h3 pawn
and not just captures captures captures
captures and we have a draw by
insufficient material sir after this
King g7 rook at five was played and they
agreed to a draw so a very nice game by
both of them Tartars tried that sneaky
idea but Capablanca saw through it I was
able to win a pawn but it was not enough
to put this opposite called Bishop +
rook in game into something more than
the draw and it's hard to say maybe I
will have more information when tariffs
book about this great tournament arrives
but for now I have no knowledge
if Capablanca pushed h5 willingly or or
he just maybe he hard to say that he
missed
check or alright he didn't go for this
rook the d2 idea but yeah maybe we'll
you know have some better better idea
when I received ours book and I don't
want to spoil anything but a certain
someone and the certain someone will
qualify into the second part of this
amazing tournament and then we will have
two two really amazing games between two
of them and also an interesting
information Capablanca face the Sigma
tariff six times in his entire life and
out of those six games tariff shut the
white pieces five times and only had
white pieces only once but still the D
and the result was in Kappa Blancas
favor an interesting fact
hope that doesn't spoil too much but
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I do hope you're enjoying my
coverage of the capablanca saga so far I
would like to thank Andrew Granado
Joseph Tabata Justin was inky Malcom
Hamilton and Fahrenheit each for a
condition to my channel thank you a lot
to really appreciate it as usual you can
check - on my previous video ER think
all for watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content you know you know how it goes I
thank you all and I will see you soon